Sony hopes to bring 3D to the masses with the PlayStation - branded 3D TV, it announced at E3 in Los Angeles.
At 24 inches, Sony said the TV is aimed at dorm rooms, bedrooms and family dens.
And that seems accurate as it would be too small for a large room.
What Sony really boasts about is that in two - player mode,...
...each player sees something different on the screen.
Ordinarily, when we're playing two - player mode,...
...it could be co-op or head-to-head, you use split - screen.
With the new technology in this display,...
...you could get full HD per person while you're wearing the glasses.
While they wouldn't let us film the screen directly,...
...I had the chance to try the effect.
And it says if there are two screens placed on top of each other,...
...and it did work as advertised,...
...the first player sees one set of images while the second player sees another.
Sony wouldn't say how it works,...
...but it likely has to do with the active shutter glasses.
The TV can play 1080p 3D movies which are playable on any PS3.
It also has additional HDMI inputs.
The screen did look a little dim but Sony said that's typical of 3D displays...
...and it wasn't helped by the bright show floor lights.
The PlayStation 3D display bundle comes with the TV, an HDMI cord,...
...Resistance 3, and one set of active shutter glasses for 500 dollars.
It goes on sale this fall.
At E3 on Los Angeles, Nick Barber, IDG News Service.